m
la bibliothèque départementale de la
réunion fête cette année ses 160 ans à
cette occasion une programmation
spécifique est prévu à la fois à la bdr
mais aussi au coin des enfants un espace
régler les ateliers créatifs pour petits
et grands en partenariat avec plusieurs
associations l'association de
scrapbooking qui proposera un atelier
adultes l'association cause
constellation qui va travailler sur
l'image ancienne
une autre association qui travaille
autour
du papier parce que nous atteler sont
vraiment ciblé sur le papier les mots
l'écriture voilà plusieurs associations
qu'on reconnaît on nantaise de nouveau
pour voir comment ça se passe ça se
passe toujours bien avec les enfants et
les adultes voilà découpage collage
créativité les enfants dû faire preuve
d'imagination pour reconstruire
l'environnement d'un animal un atelier
créatif autour du patrimoine imprimés de
la réunion mis en place par
l'association constellation l'atelier
consiste à recréer le décor dans
l'animal dans lequel vit un animal ça
peut être aussi en décor imaginaire est
la seule contrainte
ce qui est difficile pour certains
petits enfants pour pouvoir laissé à
l'imagination
c'est juste de découper et de coller en
fait donc à eux de devenir des petits
mathis du découpage et de petites formes
voilà ce qui a été fait c'est que on a
repris des images qui existait déjà
c'était des grès et des gravures ou des
instants et justement c'est l'idée
c'était de de remodeler sa de récupérer
des vieilles choses est de le faire
d'une manière pas contemporaine mais
enfantine avec ces enfants là qu'ils
puissent manipuler en fait des choses et
descend du 19e siècle
un exemple des enfants tous très fiers
de leur oeuvre chacun repartira avec sa
création sous forme de petits carnets
enfin les rangs un millier et à à porter
m
vous croyez
à tous les deux
j encore mieux en a dicté découvrir les
aides animales je les découpe et des
jeux l'écolier au centre de la feuille
après on a dit de couper plus là de
végétation par le libre mais j'ai très
fortement écrémés